in the Dominion text that came out which
were embarrassing for sure for for Fox I
mean obviously they settled the Dominion
lawsuit the techs come out he's really
rough on Trump I mean he's calling him
like this evil guy essentially anyways
this was the post-election period and
and these all come out you would think
oh that should be embarrassing and then
two weeks ago he's sitting down with
Trump for an hour-long interview in
Mar-A-Lago and and praising him in some
ways and pushing him in other ways but
this is a guy who can do can do both
those things he can be critical he can
be he has The credibility trump it will
go I mean he was just interviewed about
it what do you think about Tucker losing
his job he's sitting there praising him
this is a guy who's calling him
essentially evil in these text messages
that are coming out in the wake of the
2020 election so you lose something
massive by not having a voice like that
a guy who can it really cannot be
replaced I mean the the Legacy Media
industry is every single day even if
they were doing everything right less
and less people are watching traditional
tv less and less people are are finding
that